silver state refrigeration and hvac can
help your home in business when the
weather is hot
and they're also helping out local
charities
all right here in las vegas now and
eight news now we have the 100 degree
weather guarantee
every day from may 18 until august 31st
when the weather
hit 100 degrees or higher silver state
refrigeration donated 100
to charity needless to say was a very
hot hot summer we'll get to that in one
second
shane thank you so much for being
involved with this first off and why is
giving back to las vegas so important to
you
uh it's our pleasure and thank you for
involving us in this uh charity giveaway
uh veterans transition resource center
uh
was a no-brainer for us uh both of uh my
business partner myself are both
veterans
and so um it was a it was an easy uh
charity to think of um and the other one
was uh a home for spot which we both
have animals so it was uh
uh
over the summer as you know you may not
know we had 81 days of 100 degrees
temperature or higher so that means we
have 8 100 to give away today you're
going to split it up between two
organizations as you mentioned who is
the first check for let's who's the
first organization
this one's the veterans transition
resource center here we go
[Music]
thank you shane we appreciate that quite
a nice surprise we did not know this was
going on on our behalf
thank you so much timing couldn't be
better now where is the money gonna go
how's it gonna work
the money goes uh veterans transition
resource center is a 501c3 public
charity all volunteer
no salaries so every penny goes to
support
the foundation the veterans and their
families and our radio show we do we've
been doing a radio show educating uh the
public
on veterans issues for 10 years we air
on kdon
every saturday from noon to 1. perfect
all right the first check is done
we've got one more check to give away
all right shane check number two goes to
charity number two who is it again
this is going to a home for spot diana
come on in and get your check
congratulations oh thank you we totally
appreciate this we're
pleasantly surprised so where's this
money
gonna go this goes to our medical fund
we do about a hundred and fifty thousand
a year medical on the dogs
that the animal foundation doesn't do so
how does it feel when a charity and
when an organization like silver state
refrigeration steps up for you i want to
go hug them back
yeah oh yeah
so it's awesome right and it's a company
that you know just keeps on giving to us
they certainly do all right thank you so
much you can take your your big check
and deposit that in atm
uh shane why have you real quick what's
something everyone watching right now
should be doing at their home when it
comes to maintenance of their
their hvac system well of course every
every month or
every quarterly quarter on their air
conditioning you know they should be
changing their filters
uh changing the batteries in the
thermostats or
having calling silver state and having
them do a maintenance on their unit
that's that's a great answer the perfect
answer thank you so much for being
involved uh with this and giving back to
charity and here's to hoping that next
summer
is a super hot hot summer just so we can
raise more money and give it to more
organizations thank you so much
absolutely love doing it you can reach
silver state refrigeration
hvac and plumbing at 702-433-5008 or
visit
ssrfg.com and we
will be right back